[Music]
you may stir Hinke stand here accused of
using the dark magic known as analytics
this year knuckle here has blaspheme
against the ways of the old school this
heretic would have me rust my players I
mean it's no she the losing leads to
winning sorcery to force me to make bad
trade and give him all my draft pick
these analytics fools would have you
believe the earth is brown
do you see curve anywhere I mean I'm
just asking question and now with the
hot hand so Evan Turner is gonna
lighting your fire from a mid-range
distance
lunch
you know the guillotines probably more
efficient man shut up wit all right
let's try getting loud to hear if they
go far today it's Barack Obama and horse
really that's right the design barack
obama 44th president of the mouth
defender of grass report and the use of
data to make it move yes your birth
certificate I'll be taking the numbers
man with me thanks Obama
for where we go place far away where
innovation and new ideas are welcome the
MIT Sloan Sports analytics conference
you